we should have already had this
conversation many many years ago what
you're doing in your bedroom what you're
doing in private is affecting everybody
pornography is destroying
us Meanwhile we're trying to have a real
conversation here with my guest Senator
Dusty ders uh who is a state senator
from Oklahoma and who is one of the very
few conservatives putting his uh money
and time and effort where everyone's
mouth is and actually pushing back
against what what I consider to be the
most ubiquitous and one of the most
severe uh political problems in the
country and that is porn and weird sex
stuff Senator ders thank you for coming
on hey thank you for having me Michael I
really appreciate it Senator what is the
bill that you are proposing because the
media are making you out to be some C
who's obsessed with sex and porn and
you're pushing a fringe unconstitutional
kind of law to what hopefully ban porn
uh pornography is defiling and uh and
it's corrosive it's domineering and it's
absolutely destroying our culture and
there's really no good use for it uh and
we want to push the Supreme Court to the
test and uh you know run the Miller test
so to speak to see if there really is
any value for Oklahomans for having
pornography you mentioned the Miller
test could you explain what that is to
people who have not followed the changes
in Americans America's perception of
obscenity yeah sure um Miller versus
California in the 70s uh Supreme Court
established a
three-pronged obscenity test to
determine if speech was uh or expression
could be labeled obscene and if it is uh
protect if it's seen then it's not
protected by the First Amendment to the
US Constitution and so it can be
prohibited and uh you know those there
three tests essentially the first one is
the arousal test uh whether the average
person applying uh you know our
contemporary Community standards would
find the work uh as a whole puant or it
arousing uh the second would be
offensive or the uh kind of the uh gag
reflex uh test and and then the third
would be a serious value test where it
asks if the material uh lacks serious
literary or artistic or political or
scientific value so we really are
looking from from the state of Oklahoma
we're saying look the constitution of
our nation does not protect obscenity
Supreme Court has also upheld that it
doesn't protect obscenity and the
Constitution also according to the 10th
Amendment says that that Oklahoma has
the right to protect its own people and
so we are essentially just saying do the
people of Oklahoma a jury in Oklahoma uh
want pornography and uh really the
reality is uh from a legal level we
should have already had this
conversation many many years ago uh but
the the truth is up until about 40 or 50
years ago uh we didn't have to have this
conversation the ual Revol revolution
has pushed uh this conversation into the
front to say really what is what is
what's the good in obscenity for our
nation and we've proven that it's
completely corrosive to our society you
you mentioned how 40 50 years ago we
wouldn't have had to have this
conversation of course we had laws
against obscenity all over the country
we had a much lower threshold for what
constitutes obscenity for the vast
majority of our Nations history they
raise it a little bit uh like in Miller
or some other decisions as well but I
agree with you even but by any modern
conception of what constitutes obscenity
high-speed ubiquitous internet
pornography falls into that category I
agree with you that there's an appetite
for it they tried it twice in the 90s uh
there was at the national level the
communications decency Act and the child
online protection act Republicans and
Democrats supported it Bill Clinton
signed it into law and then liberal
judges applying crazy uh UNH
antihistorical standards uh shot those
both down and so now we have this
problem that we we have now rather than
nipping it in the bud 20 25 years ago
why is porn such a big issue you're
going to have people on the left and and
you're going to have some Libertarians
say oh well yeah it's kind of naughty
and nasty but why why do you care what
someone does in his own bedroom and is
this really the biggest issue we got an
invasion on the southern border we got
an economy in shambles You Porn isn't
that kind of far down the list of
priorities yeah yeah that's a great
question that that question's popped up
a lot and I'd say a few things number
one every person looking at porn knows
that it is condemning them there's not a
single person who looks at it and says
oh this is a good thing for me this is a
good thing for the people that I'm
watching here this what I'm seeing
happen here even if it's less violent uh
is a good thing there nobody is saying
that because they have a conscience
they're created by God and their
conscience is either approving them or
accusing them before the holy character
of God so they already know number one
secondly porn is defiling and what we
see in the bedroom spills out into the
outdoors what happens indoors is always
going to go outdoors with porn it
disfigures one one's view of everything
that is good and true and beautiful I
mean think of the the modern art that we
have it's ugly it's meant to defile and
to break boundaries it's
transgressive it is doing everything to
to it's it's truly Pagan porn comes from
a pagan sensibility of Oneness monism
rather than there's God and the and then
there's everything that's created it
wants to disfigure everything transgress
it all and create a a truly a uh a queer
Theory worked out uh just from the
initial stages and another thing is porn
is domineering it is a wildfire that
cannot be controlled and it it Taps into
the voracious insatiable app appetite of
the corrupted flesh it's never satisfied
let me tell you what Ted Bundy said a
lot of people have heard this but some
people in our in the younger generation
have not heard that Ted Bundy he was a
serial killer admitted to killing uh
over 30 people and he said this in
prison like most most other kinds of
addiction I would keep looking for more
potent more explicit more graphic kinds
of material like an addiction you keep
craving something which is harder harder
something which gives you a greater
sense of excitement until you reach the
point that pornography only goes so far
he said that pornography is what led him
down the path of doing these Wicked and
heinous serial killings and then he said
this I've lived in prison a long time
now I've met a lot of men were motivated
to commit violence just like me and
without exception every one of them was
deeply involved in pornography without
question without exception deeply
influenced and consumed by addiction to
pornography it is not merely what
happens indoors it's going outdoors and
it's even going outdoors and creating I
think the corrosive level of society
that we've got right now so we've got to
destroy that which is destroying our
foundations and it's destroying the
foundations particularly in the home and
there's no question that Satan and the
and in his Serpentine theocracy is
wanting to create a whole another system
where he rules and where God's holy
character is not the standard where you
see in Traditional Values and
traditional families it is destroying us
it's such a simple clear point that
you're making and it's something that
that even a lot of people on the right
have forgotten just as you can't
separate body from Soul I guess the
transgender activists are trying to do
that now just as gnostics have been
doing that for all of history nothing
new Under the Sun I guess it's all old
versions of paganism but just as you
can't separate from the the body from
the soul you can't separate the person
in the bedroom from the person in the
streets it's the same person you you
can't actually live two lives a lot of
people are duplicit this a lot of people
Endeavor to lead two lives but you're
the same guy and it will disfigure your
mind it will disfigure your perception
might well disfigure your body and the
the proof of this is that we were told
in the 90s oh you know just let people
do whatever they want in the bedroom
it's no big deal stop being the Purity
police whatever and then what five
minutes later you you've got massive
Pride parades in the streets with guys
wearing weird leather outfits and
smacking each other and inviting
children to these kinds of parades and
then they say oh it's no big deal it's a
you know the children probably shouldn't
even be at those parades well okay first
of all it's in public but second of all
they don't leave it in the street then
all of a sudden the activism makes it
into the classroom then all of the the
sudden the activism gets codified in law
to the point that now you've got school
administrators encouraging children and
enabling children to take dangerous
chemicals hormones block their puberty
call them different names use the wrong
bathroom without their parents'
permission you know at what point was
that supposed to just stop at what you
know the conservatives were always
pillared for saying this is a slippery
slope and man is a being you know man is
a a unified being with Integrity so what
he does in one realm is going to affect
him in another realm well I mean we're
pretty far down that slope as it is and
I can hear the objections to you Senator
what people are going to say is this guy
he's some Yoko from Oklahoma some bible
thumper with a funny accent and he's
talking well this guy probably wants a
theocracy or something and they're going
to brush over the fact that you are
citing philosophy you're citing
psychology you're citing science you're
citing you're citing basically
everything we can know about how
individuals and societies have worked
for all of history and they're going to
write this off and say well you know
you're just some bible thumper so what
do you say to them well I think none of
them wants their daughter to grow up uh
as an only fans um celebrity
you know and that's the truth is porn
there's no closed door porn what you're
doing in your bedroom what you're doing
in private is affecting my children it's
affecting my my friends it's affecting
everybody so uh we get our rights from
God government doesn't give us our
rights we our constitution says this
very thing we get our rights from God
and so then we have to ask what is
Liberty well you have the Liberty to do
that which is good for society the
government stands in to protect goodd
doers and punish evildoers and when
there's an evildoer who is stripping
away and something that's evil that's
taking over a society and it's stripping
away the good the true the beautiful
there's no Liberty to do that now at
some point we're having to make
decisions at what what's kind of bumps
up to that level of crime and not all
sin is crime uh but this pornography has
come to the level uh that a nobody
recognizes that it's good that it's got
any truth or any value it's not good
it's not true it's not beautiful it is
absolutely degrading and defiling and
it's domineering it is controlling and
it's not as though it's free from a
controll
uh higher power that higher
principalities and Powers that's exactly
right it's principalities powers and
rulers of the air and they are setting
up and Waging War against humanity and
what is good right and true is from God
who created us and so this is it is a
power it's a spiritual warfare and these
people are are getting anyone who gets
caught up into the pornography is caught
up not just in a power of Flesh blood
but a power that they aren't able to
control that's degrading them and
seeking to eradicate their use their
value and true Society one last question
before I let you go I I know that you're
right when you say at least that pretty
much no one thinks this stuff is good in
fact I just interviewed a journalist who
did an undercover investigation of
senior staff for the biggest porn
company in the world even the senior
staff are saying yeah this is bad it's
creates addictions it's not good however
there was one person that this
journalist ardin young interviewed and
he said no you know if you're a kid and
you're you stumble on to this kind of
stuff it can help you explore your
sexuality it can liberate you and I have
heard liberals say that that
pornography and the sexual Revolution
more broadly you know it helps free you
from the shackles that might have been
imposed on you and helps you to discover
your true desires and your true self and
what what might really get rid of all
the chains of Oppression foisted on you
by your family and morality and society
and blah blah blah what do you say to
these self-styled liberators well Satan
said the same thing to Adam and Eve
whenever he first came to them and the
first words we have from a supernatural
being in the whole of scripture other
than God is did God really say did God
really say and what Satan was doing was
setting up a war in the consci
says the conscience was created by god
it works according to the law that's
written on our hearts every person has
it but Satan is wanting to set up a
internal war of Envy we don't have
enough of what God has given us so we
have to Envy some other outlet and we
start to recognize ourselves as true
gods and that's what porn the lust of
the eyes the lust of the Flesh and the
pride of life the lust of the eyes and
the lust the flesh is what porn is 1
John 2 uh so it's setting up the Envy of
godhood that we are not wanting to
retain our position as creatures who are
creating the image of God and who are
who are here to enjoy him forever and
enjoy each other according to God's good
boundaries we then want to Envy godhood
just like Satan did he put that
question out there and we've been
questioning so this you know libertarian
who is actually Waring against the true
Liberty uh this libertarian type of a
mindset or libertine really mindset
would ask the very question that Satan
asked Adam and Eve did God really say
and then it's you can be God because I'm
trying to be God as well a very
insightful Point Senator ders and a very
courageous and important Bill uh thank
you very much for coming on thank you
for fighting this fight and being one of
the handful of Republicans in America at
the state level who has a spine
appreciate you coming on hey thanks for
having me
Michael